[Musique]
bonsoir jean claude de femmes merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
joe biden qui commence donc à dévoiler
son futur gouvernement alors que toi me
continue ses recours pour contester sa
défaite
anthony blinken à la diplomatie john
terry pour le climat pour la première
fois un hispanique alejandro mayorkas ça
la sécurité intérieure que vous
inspirent ces premiers noms dévoilés
bonsoir tout simplement trop bas et des
choix vie des gens qu'il connaît qui ont
travaillé avec lui leur saison sur la
période donc ils sont où j'allais dire
d'un cercle rapproché des personnes
qu'il connaît et dans lequel il ya jean
pierre confiance centre ont porté
attention à leur orientation idéologique
à l'intérieur du parti
qu'est ce qu'il y a quand vous savez
l'intérieur du parti démocrate qui a
réédité pour ne pas saisir trois qu'il y
avait aussi une grande diversité sur les
choix de politique économique risque aux
financiers
or là on voit paille dench pas dire ce
que j'appellerais garde rapprochée pour
l'instant aucune conclusion qu'un dessin
sur ce que pourrait être par exemple la
politique étrangère puisque anthony
blinken
la tête de la diplomatie on peut en
tirer certaines réflexions
non je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
changement sur maman tôt dans la vie de
la politique projet est historiquement a
fait dix parties à ce qu'on peut
attendre ce qu'effectivement des
changements de style peut-être des et
d'ailleurs qui sont un peu moins proche
peut-être que les relations avec
l'espagne par la bce ni trop un peu plus
qui se tendent qu'elle ne l'était du
temps de trois mais je crois pas qu'il
ya la barrière sur son portable avec la
chine est encore froid avec paris
oui effectivement puisque joe biden
avait annoncé que la russie était
certainement pour lui l'un des pays les
plus menaçants lors d'une interview à
une chaîne
américaine fin de la parenthèse alors
sur les trente trois recours déposés par
l'équipe de donald trump 22 ont déjà été
retoqué ce week-end en pennsylvanie un
juge fédéral a rejeté les accusations de
fraude
c'est un coup dur pour l'équipe trump
l'étau se resserre ça va être compliqué
d'inverser la tendance
je crois que vous allez je crois qu'il
faut se voir les choses avec un certain
recul
ce n'est pas en train de se passer c'est
qu'il ya eu effectivement un certain
nombre de recours et que ces recours
portent sur des chiffres qui ne
permettent pas d'inverser le résultat
est à peu près 5 6 et a dit en ponts
bascules son appel il explique state qui
effectuent quant aux données la victoire
finale à baïnem par simplement de sièges
au niveau du collège électoral il y aura
plus de 300 ans ou 260 aucun des états
l'a montré même avec des ajustements de
bain parce qu'il ya eu essaieront des
centres existent huit ans on parle de
quelques dizaines ou quelques centaines
d oie et à baden a gardé a gagné par des
majorités délai de dix villes 15 mise
donc rien ainsi dira andré cependant
faire il n'en prenons pas de bascule
d'état et donc le 14 200 quand les
délégués au collège électoral vent sont
réunis rappeur et bien ils confirmeront
que baye est effectivement le président
et m donc je crois que tout ça c'est
même si je puis dire des combats
d'arrière-garde jetons payeurs c'est le
pitch de plus en plus générale vers
check et 10 kg piques qui traque les
pabx remettre en cause les résultats de
l'élection et de constituer un courant
est fort ce soit pour se protéger
d'éventuelles poursuites judiciaires ou
de deux problèmes il y là un futur c'est
quand même un peu compliqué il a échappé
non d'affaires qui a été mise en suspens
parce que il était le président alors
qu'il avait utilisé deux fonctions mais
il a des affaires à titre personnel
agressions et autres
donc du béret et où elles n'en ont pas
en tout cas il n'a pas été jugé les
enquêtes fiscales
il a aussi des problèmes avec certains
de ces banques ont tout ça ce sont des
pantins qui l'attendent
et donc il est de bonne guerre susis
d'essayer de trouver un ou deux thèmes
qui permettent de pain ont abordé ces
questions de soto je crois que lui
laissant en point se représenter en 2024
selouane 2024
donc ce qui est intéressant de noter
d'ailleurs en faire et parce que ces
élections c'est que tout le monde parle
de la victoire de bayonne qui n'est pas
contesté elle n'est pas véritablement
contester sérieusement contesté en
revanche ce que sid hayden a été élu
c'est surtout parce qu'il était mon
titre mais en revanche les démocrates
n'ont pas fait de bons est une belle ils
ont perdu des voix à la chambre et au
sénat
ils n'ont pas la majorité qui pourrait
la voir si longtemps fait les deux
sièges qui sont en réflexion au début du
mois de janvier
et c'est là d'ailleurs on retrouve la
stratégie d'un support de républicains
qui ne veulent pas laisser tomber trappe
trop tôt parce qu'il a besoin de gens de
son soutien pour faire élire ses deux
sénateurs en chirurgie qui sont
essentiels pour la majorité est du
québec
merci en tout cas jean todt un gruffalo
homme d'affaires franco américain
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir